thanks so much for speaking with me
today I saw the film this afternoon and
was just floored by it I heard that
they're your first cut of the film was
was much longer than the two-hour cut is
that true or okay the first cut was I
want to see two hours and five minutes
which is not so bad you know the movie
the final cut is about an hour of 50 so
undone with credits you know it becomes
two hours so so I would say it's about
15 minutes longer it's one of the things
that really sort of jumped out at me at
this film there you have this sort of
that's a very cerebral emotionally
driven story but then occasionally
you'll get this sort of violent set
piece and I was kind of curious about
the construction of those set pieces cuz
they sort of tell kind of like a history
of violence in their own way yeah we had
intended the thing to be almost like
broad and subtle you know that the thing
would have moments of introspection and
then there would be explosion explosions
and an introspection and explosions and
that sort of thing would keep you on
your toes and allow you to delve even
more deeply into the stuff that was very
introspective it was all part of the
design really and we were trying to say
space doesn't really want us out there
it's hostile to us because it's
indifferent to us and we thought part of
the way to show that was a kind of
explosiveness know that that alienation
and loneliness really sort of seeps
through and in the film and really sort
of envelops you
I was curious sort of you know with your
approach to shooting it and especially
trying to shoot in that sort of zero-g
like environment what are the challenges
in trying to to make that believable
it's the biggest pain in the rear you
could possibly imagine I don't know how
our fans or who are on did it for
gravity I think he did it with dizzy
doubles and you know putting faces on
digital so that is a remarkable
achievement I don't know how he kept his
sanity it's incredible we tried to do it
in a little bit more of a kind of
I don't want to say primitive way but we
try to conjure the the methods of
Kubrick for example and what he did was
and what we did was we built two
versions of the sets the horizontal
version and a vertical version same set
and you would do the close-ups in the
horizontal and then when he needed to be
zero gravity Brad would hang from wires
and we would shoot through the camera
looking up at him as he was hanging and
it's pretty convincing a zero-g but it
is not what you want to be doing all day
you know it here's about your use of
close-up in the film how well it tells
the story and Ferb breezes into McBride
sites one of the great weapons in the
history of the cinema I mean I don't
know who invented it maybe is Edwin
Porter great train robber I know it's
hard to know but you imagine the first
person who I ever used a movie camera
they thought oh I'm gonna give you this
where's the rest of the body whoever
discovered this understood that the
actor can reveal much more about him or
herself by saying nothing at all in the
cinema because the camera sees right
through you in a close-up that's a
weapon
we know we can understand emotionally
what care is going to the actors going
through when the cameras really close
you mentioned Kubrick and it's funny
because I'm watching this film like this
is 2001 Meets Apocalypse Now and it was
just were those some of your
inspirations for this it was but you
know the funny thing is I'm gonna say
something very pretentious here our
first inspiration we tried to do the
Odyssey from the Telemachus point of
view you know this goes away but you
know the movie becomes something
different and then the to start the 2001
on the apocalypse now mashup idea which
I completely really is because the
Kubrick film adheres to an authentic
view of space travel
and apocalypse has that kind of mythic
heart of darkness thread and so if you
put those two together I guess you got
this this sort of I would say you know
as I don't want to say you you edged out
Apocalypse Now but I did like that
there's an emotional connection between
you know your Willard and your curves
story I mean it's just a symbolic father
in Apocalypse Now and here it's his
actual father or we were trying to do
something very mythic we were trying to
conjure a story of father and son we
thought that the tenderness I mean could
only be achieved by that biological
relationship well thank you so much for
talking with me I loved the film and
just congratulations on